kavik River Camp is 197 miles north of
the Arctic Circle and sue Aikens its
sole caretaker is in a constant battle
against mother nature Frieza
marks the time of year when caribou and
other animals migrate south as the
Tundra's food sources thin out predators
become more desperate I am a food group
I'm not top of the food chain so every
day every morning every night I've got
to look for predators I'm fully aware in
my mind I live in their territory they
do not live in mine there's more stuff
that wants to eat me than I want to be
eaten by out here it's always a
challenge just staying alive day to day
all animals figure out where other
animals sleep where are they denting up
where are they betting down yeah he's
testing my line really big crunching
he was here there's no time yeah don't
go too far it's exactly what a predator
wants to do
[Applause]
right there you can tell the footprints
it's I mean I'm 10 to 1 pretty sure it's
either the wolf or the Wolverine my
heart was racing a little bit but I mean
this is what it is to live in the Arctic
but for me to go out there to
investigate that's what a predator does
he draws you away from her from your
safety zone and I stand my ground I'll
look but no way I'm coming inside they
want to get me they're coming right in
here tomorrow morning when it's light
I'll go look at tracks tonight a
son-of-a-bitch got to get in here to get
me I'm probably not gonna sleep very
much but if anybody wants to play poker
I got the winning hand right here